[music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
[music] diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of [music] your
primary care physician. statements in
this program have not been evaluated by
the FDA. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We're honored
to continue and
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. The
content is not intended to diagnose,
treat, cure, or prevent any diseases,
[music]
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician.
Testimonials [music]
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual sharing their testimony.
[music] Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
[music] regarding health or income. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
have the founding father of the science
of epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health, Dr. Joel Wallik.
>> Yeah. Hello everybody. Welcome to Daily
with Doc and Becca. Thanks for being
here. Let's go ahead and open up that
waiting room. We'll let people in. As
this is a live show, if you are watching
us on a live stream or even a replay,
you are welcome to join us live Monday
through Friday from 12 to 100 p.m.
Pacific time. That's 1 to 2 Mountain, 23
Central, 3 to 4 Eastern and beyond. And
if you're in Alaska, I think you're an
hour behind. So 11 to 12. We are here
Monday through Friday because we know
there are so many people out there that
are searching for options. The medical
model has failed them. They continue to
get more and more prescriptions and not
finding the health that they want. Well,
folks, we're not chemical deficient.
We're nutrient deficient. Okay, think
about that. We're not chemical
deficient. or nutrient division. And I
can't think of a better individual who
has been studying and observing the
effects of nutrition for over 75 years.
Yes. Over 75 years being observant and
recognizing the value of nutrition. What
goes in? What doesn't go in? What
happens when things don't go in? What
happens when things do go in? Folks, it
has to do with nutrition, toxicity, what
we have in our environment, what is
going into our mind.
All of these things are part of holistic
health. And that is one thing that I am
very much passionate about is making
sure that individuals realize
that your thoughts matter as well. But
today, thinking of thoughts, we're going
to be talking about brain and spinal
issues
as we have Dr. Joel Wallik here with us.
Um, the t title of today's show
is
where'd it go? Where'd it go? Dr. Dr.
Wallik's wonderful wellness solutions
for brain and spinal issues. Yes, they
are connected physically. literally
they're connected. And today we're going
to be talking about what we as
individuals can do to help support that
part of our body. So if you are new to
finding us, welcome. Congratulations.
You are taking that first step into
investing into your health as you are
spending the next hour with us learning
about what you can do. not only what you
can do but underlying causes of what's
going on and then the solutions to
change that underlying cause.
Get back with the person that shared
this program with you. If somebody
shared you shared this program with you,
tell them thank you and make sure that
if you have any questions that they are
your point of contact
as we are a resource for an amazing
community of individuals who are
coaches, health coach coaches, certified
holistic health coaches, life coaches,
massage therapists, all different
modalities in the alternative medicine
which I personally think should is the
original medicine. And even those that
are in the modern day
matrix of medicine, folks, so many
people are waking up to the value
that nutrition brings to health. And I'm
super excited that we're able to share
that with you at least five days a week
as we bring empowering information to
the world.
My name is Becca Dukes. As the director
of student services for the Institute of
Holistic Health, the hostess of this
program and a coach to a lot of coaches,
I am honored to be able to also present
the man who started this crusade, who
started
with with making sure people understand
that there is another science beyond
genetics, and that's called epigenetics,
folks. Epigenetics
proves that the theory of disease
transmission
which is said to be genetic is false.
So if they can't figure out the
underlying cause of something they blame
it on genetics.
Now there are things that are genetic
absolutely hair color, eye color, shape
of our face, color of our skin, you know
even the way our feet are shaped. Yes,
that can be part of genetics.
But when it comes to health,
nutritional deficiencies can even affect
birth defects, folks, not genetics.
And we have with us one of the founding
fathers of that science of epigenetics,
who has 26 books that he has written
written. 25 are readily available on his
website drjwallik.com.
And the second of those 26 is held as a
national treasure in the Smithsonian
Museum and that is diseases of exotic
animals. As yes, the doctor that we we
have on us with us, yes, is a
naturopathic physician. He can treat
humans. He can legally give information
to support humans. But he started out as
a veterinarian. After obtaining a
bachelor of science in plant and soil
sciences, he went on to be a doctor of
veterary medicine. He was working his
way through college in the pathology lab
where he saw a lot of different things.
And that started him being able to look
at the cells, look at the the the
composition
of everything that was coming through
there. Comparing
because it's comparative pathology,
folks. Comparing what's there and what
disease or mishaps or dysfunction is
going on within the body. Now, that
started out as animals. Yes. But
that led him to be part of an amazing
expedition to save the white rhino in
South Africa.
He was there two years. He got called
back. He was then working at the Yorks
Primate Center where he found the first
nonhuman case of cystic fibrosis that is
supposed to be a human genetic disease.
He proved that not only is it only human
and not only human, he also proved that
it's not genetic because there were
several of these monkeys not related
that had the same conditions
and it had to do with what they were
being fed. He proved it. He got fired.
Imagine that. But one thing about
getting fired is it opens the doors to
being able to do bigger and greater
things.
which he did. He started teaching
nutrition at a naturopathic college. He
also became a naturopath. While there,
he opened up clinics and decided that
what was on the market was not enough.
So, he got a team together. They
formulated some nutritional products. He
started recommending them to his
patients. They got better. And there's
this joke, he treats you like a dog, but
you do get better. I get it. I was one
of them. And from there, he wanted to go
bigger and better. So, he created this
crusade to go beyond the four walls of
his clinics to reach around the world.
And he did that by opening up an
opportunity in a company that started
out as American Longevity, wanted to go
beyond the American borders and changed
it to Young Jevity International.
This is an opportunity that allows
individuals like you and I to be able to
share the good news of nutrition and
options and we are empowered with others
and get a thank you check. So I just
want to give a huge thank you to Dr.
Joel Wallik for all that he has done.
Because of him, I have been able to
regain my health. Thank you, Dr. Wallik.
Overcoming hormonal things, overcoming
um muscular and connective tissue
things, overcoming bone issues,
overcoming migraines that started at the
age of eight. And if that wasn't enough,
doc, there's like 13 different things
that I was able to let go of because of
your teachings and recommendations, Dr.
Wallik, and 100 pounds is part of that.
So folks,
I welcome to the screen with me Dr. Joel
Wallik who has four postdoates. Is it
three? No, three post-doates in
pathology. He has done research around
the world including
1,700
1700 children that had died of unknown
causes
that they discovered the cause. They
discovered
well it was Kon disease which is
actually they they just died of heart
attacks under the age of 10 folks
and it be was because of nutritional
deficiencies.
So, Dr. Wallik, thank you for being
here. Thank you for starting this
crusade and thank you for continuing to
share knowledge that is empowering that
we can actually act upon and share with
others. You're awesome, Doc.
>> Well, thank you so much, Rebecca, for
the kind uh going through some of the
history. And of course, that was just
the beginning. That was just the
beginning. opening the door. And it it
proved to me that the medical science
was really really um treating symptoms
to make the patients happy, which is in
itself not a bad thing. But
>> somebody would die in two years after
being treated for two years. They were
happy because they didn't have the
symptoms, but the disease killed them
because they're treating symptoms, not
treating the disease. Okay?
[clears throat] And so um working my way
through veterary school, working my way
through naturopathic school, I'm seeing
all these things on the autopsy table.
And
one of the big ones, of course, are
diseases of the brain and spinal cord.
This goes way way back in history, okay?
Because of people's eating habits. And
of course, one of my favorite little
um two or three word
cures is a stick of butter a day keeps
the doctor away. A stick of butter keeps
margarine kills. Okay, because margarine
causes all kinds of um inflammation,
okay? It's heated oils, not good.
Whereas butter, people tend not to
overheat it because they don't want to
burn. They leave it melt at a a safe
cooking level and it actually gives your
brain spinal cord some of the stuff it
needs to keep going. And of course,
we have um babies that are born with
gender problems. That's a brain and
spinal cord issue. They're born with
gender problems because the mother was
not given the right vitamins and
minerals. Um well, I'm not planning on
getting pregnant. I don't need some
prenatal vitamins. Well, yeah, you do.
just in case. And that's why we have so
many kids now. We have so many kids now.
Little girls think they're boys, little
boys think they're girls. We have all
these gender issues in sports and all
kinds of things. It's like crazy. And I
I point my finger at the OBGYn
at this and general family practitioners
at this, okay? Because they should be
telling people to be taking vitamins and
minerals, both men and women, okay?
um when they're just kids. That's what
we came up with kids taught vitamins and
minerals and we came up with a liquid
they kids because they think it's a a
fruit juice kind of thing. Kids taught
it and gives them the nutrients
necessary. So when pregnancy does occur,
okay, when they're 16 years old or 18
years old or 20 years old or 40 years
old or 50 years old or whatever, um the
babies will come out recognizing their
gender, okay, properly. Now, this goes
way back thousands of years, okay? And
of course, we used to see this in big
farms and ranches thousands of years ago
all over the world. Um cows, let's say,
had a herd of of um maybe
eight or 10 or 12 or 15 or 20 milk cows
and all the herd will want to jump on
one cow. All the females and males want
to jump on one cow and breed her. Okay.
Because she was kind of giving them the
signals that she was a girl. Okay. No,
she was giving them signals. Yeah. That
she was a girl. But what happened was
when her mother was pregnant, the mother
didn't get all the vitamins and minerals
for whatever reason. and the baby was
born without the ability to make all the
right hormones. Okay? So, they came out
with male hormones in that particular
cow as opposed to female hormones. Well,
in the old days, you know, a couple
hundred years ago, a thousand years ago,
they would just kill them and eat them.
Same way with the boys. The boys would
think they're girls and they let the the
boy, you know, steers and the the male
bulls breed them, but they're, you know,
anal sex instead. Hey, that's the only
thing that they could do. And so they
would just kill that one and eat them.
Okay. And that went on for thousands of
years.
>> Okay. And so now we we know the answer
to that in the in the in the livestock
industry, okay? The health and veterary
industry. And it's still going on with
people, okay? Because all these girls
are not taking all the vitamins and
minerals. And let's say they get
pregnant when they're eight or 10 years
old. I'd like to see a survey that tells
me I want to know at what age the
mothers were when they had a baby who
grew up to think little girl thinking
she was a boy and a little boy think it
was a girl. I want to know how old those
people were, those women were when they
got pregnant for that pregnancy. Okay?
Because that's totally preventable.
Totally preventable. It is not just
something the kid come makes things up
said, "Well, I'm a girl." You know, you
have all the equipment of a boy or a
boy. I am a girl. That's why I have all
this stuff on the sports and is going
on. And it's just terrible. That's
because mama made mistakes. Because the
doctors, the nurses, and made mistakes
by not telling them what needed to be
done
10 years ago, five years ago, three
years ago, 100 years ago, thousand years
ago. Okay. And so this problem will keep
going on until people wake up and start
realizing you must give all the n all
the nutrients to these women who are um
even if they're not having sex at that
time. Make sure they're getting all the
the nutrients because at one night they
have sex and they get pregnant, that
baby's born, little girl thinks she's a
boy and a little boy thinks he's a girl.
That's because mama didn't have the
nutrients to make all the proper things
work properly as the baby came towards
puberty. Okay.
>> So, doc, before you move on, I want to
inject just a little bit. This is not
just Dr. Wallick coming up with this
thinking that it's some type of theory.
This is actually been proven through
other studies after Dr. Wallik started
talking about it, including one coming
out of Swedish researchers that found
that the physical attributes of a
homosexual brain resemble those of the
opposite sex. So that has to do with
nutrition and in development,
not just something that happens
afterwards and is influenced by society
even. So it is something that Dr.
Wallik, we start people off with
nutrition before they're conceived on
through [clears throat]
the rest of their lives
because it's like putting gas in the
car, right?
>> That is correct. You can't put water in
a car,
>> right? You're gonna if you're going to
run your vehicle, you got to keep keep
feeding it and that's what the nutrition
is to the body. So, thank you Dr. Wallik
for letting me insert that. Please go
ahead.
>> Okay. So any rate, some of the stuff is
in this tool, okay? Dead doctors don't
lie. Dr. Milan likes the subtitle.
Someone should go to jail. She she likes
Dr. Milan likes that subtitle. Okay, but
it's really um dead lie. Okay, it's two
hours and eight minutes. And it's one of
those things we can show to one person
in your house, your office. You can show
it to your in your den at home to 10,
12, 15 people. You can show it to a
class with 25 people with 50 people in a
classroom stadium with a thousand people
or more. You'll have to have five or six
different projectors so that all corners
get to show. But this particular tool
goes into really what we're talking
about today. We're talking about on the
back cover of this goes into
30 different 30 different chapters.
Okay? And it goes into these kind of
things. We just got done talking about
genetics and DNA. Okay. Um
they tend to be irrelevant.
Okay. You need to just be given the the
mama that has the possibility of getting
pregnant just because she's a girl. She
might not be having sex yet, but just
because she's a girl, maybe six months
down the line, two years down the line,
five years down the line, she get
pregnant and she wasn't taking vitamins
and minerals the whole time. The baby
can come out. Little girl has all this
physical equipment. A little girl thinks
she's a boy. All the little boy physical
equipment of a boy thinks he's a girl.
Okay. ADD and ADHD, autism,
vaccinations,
um Alzheimer's disease.
Okay. And we're talking about Parkinson
disease. There's hundreds of different
diseases that occur
in the brain and spinal cord. They're
all totally preventable.
They're all totally preventable. And um
what should I say? Um
because some of my favorites of course
are Parkinson's disease. We get rid of
Parkinson disease all the time. I don't
care if you've had it for 25 years. In
two weeks you'll see improvement. And
that's why I always say give me 90 days
because usually I don't care if you've
had Parkinson disease for 25 years. We
can get rid of it in two months or two
weeks. Same way with type two diabetes.
I don't care if you've had it your whole
life. You've had type two diabetes for
15, 20, 30, 40 years and in two weeks
time you can be diabetes free. Okay?
Because these are all just simple
nutritional deficiency diseases. This is
not difficult and um Alzheimer disease
is a global disease. In other words, the
entire brain gets afflicted when you
have Alzheimer disease and it loses the
myelin white matter of the brain and it
loses the myelin in the brain. Medical
doctors set that off too because what is
the raw material, Rebecca? What's the
raw material to make myelin?
>> Cholesterol.
>> Cholesterol. Well, doctors say that's
bad. It clogs your artery. You can't
have cholesterol. No, you need
cholesterol because it it's what makes
the mile and the white matter of your
brain's spinal cord. It also makes the
hormones for males and females.
Cholesterol is your best friend. Our sex
hormones are like 85 90% cholesterol.
Your brain is 85% cholesterol. And if
you take those free pills doctors are
giving you to lower your cholesterol,
you're going to wind up with Parkinson's
disease, Alzheimer's disease, multiple
scerosis, ALS, Huntington's Korea, front
of temporal dementia, charcoal puly,
cervical spinalosis, carpal tunnel
syndrome, brain spinal cord tumors, and
there's another
those diseases. I could go down the
list, but you know, myopathy, optic
neuropathies, progressive inflammatory
neuropathy, on and on and on. These
things are all caused by a deficiency
of the raw materials to make the myelin
which is the the cholesterol. Okay. I I
came up many years ago when people I'm
saying stop using margarine use butter.
Well, my doctor says I have to use
margarine because butter clogs your
arteries. No, a stick of butter day
keeps the doctor away. I came up with
that little funny statement that that
okay, a stick of a stick of butter a day
keeps the doctor away. I still say that.
And so it's one of those things where
we have this flip chart. Everybody
should have I mean remember the holidays
are coming up. If you buy 10 of these,
you get a nice discount. Um the
page 27 goes into
um one of our famous cases where we got
rid of a um Parkinson disease and a gal
maline O her last name begins with an O
and it's one of those things where
the
what she was going to the best
neurologist to a big big medical school
on the east coast and getting worse and
worse and worse and worse and after
about 10 11 years the doctors told her
family look she might not wake up
tomorrow morning she's really bad now
her tests are just awful and so be
prepared get ready it's coming okay well
one of her relatives a member of young
okay asked is there anything we can do
yeah so I told him what to do and to
make a long story short in two months
she didn't have Parkinson disease
anymore there you go 90 for life say she
didn't have Parkinson disease anymore so
they redid all the tests the next day
and they came back normal again. It
freaked everybody out. So she she wrote
many letters to us and telling us, you
know, kind of step by step how she was
doing for that two and a half months and
getting better. And so we highlighted
the salient points in yellow and we put
them in the right hand side of page 27,
the slip chart. There you go. There you
go. Thank you. And on the left hand side
we got a page and a half of from letters
from doctors who are saying I can't
believe this I've seen it myself blah
blah blah blah. And so she's been going
around with her relatives in longevity
given talks and and helping other people
all over the world about how to prevent
and get rid of Parkinson's disease.
Parkinson disease is not a genetic
thing. It's not an old age thing. It's a
simple nutritional deficiencies. That's
why we came out with
the stick of butter keeps doctor away.
And of course we have the i26. We have
the i26.
I began using that. Right. And I think
we bought the company. We acquired the
company. Right.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Acquired company I think about nine
years ago. Dr. Wallik.
>> Okay. We acquired it nine years ago.
Chewables. Okay. I like the French
vanilla. And then of course, uh, it
comes in capsules. I keep those on the
side. I take a couple of those every
week just just in case. And then also,
um, it comes in powder. You mix the
powder in with liquids. And see that
bottom canister there is, you know, the
top. Yeah. Top and bottom. Okay.
Is the
>> Yeah. So So th this one is unflavored.
There's no artificial flavors. There's
no artificial um sweeteners. No, not
even natural sweeteners or flavors. And
this is just pure I26 Hyper Egg immune
powder. You mix it in cool water and it
tastes like the shell of an Eclair. Dr.
Wick, I really like it. And then for
those that want a little bit of flavor,
they just just recently came out with
the French Vanilla, which is the same
formula of the chewables that Dr. Wallik
likes, just in a powder that you can mix
in water instead of having to chew them.
So, lots of options there, Doc.
>> Yep. And of course, the benefits are,
what should I say, are breathless. The
the benefits are breathless because when
you think about it, that we can prevent
and reverse
Alzheimer's disease, which is a global
thing in the brain. Parkinson's disease,
okay, we can get rid of that. And
Parkinson disease is a loss of myelin in
one little part of the brain. Okay,
let's see. What is it? um u
substanti it's just a little patch you
know about the size of a 50 cent piece
in the middle of your brain and it helps
you with balance so when that's when
that gets gone because you don't have
enough raw materials to make the mile
myin the white matter of the brain
suddenly now you get these tremors okay
I'm 85 years old and I don't have these
trimmers I'm 85 years old I don't have
any of these trimmers okay I don't have
them it's one of those things where
that's because I've
eating butter all my life. I'm a farm
boy. Well, you'd get beat up. If you're
on a dairy farm, you'd eat margarine.
Okay?
And and so it's one of those things when
you learn, just think about it. If you
have in your family or your neighbors or
your church mates, your workmates,
Alzheimer disease, Parkinson disease,
multiple scerosis, ALS, Huntington
Korea, Shercom, Bell's palsy, and I
could go on and on and on again. carpal
tunnel syndrome, brain spinal cord
tumors, front of temporal dementia, all
those are reversible.
Okay, by taking the 90 essential
nutrients and the I26,
I take two or three of those I26 every
morning, every late afternoon, I take
them. And sometimes if I'm going to be
doing something heavily physical, I'll
take three, three times a day instead of
just twice a day. But I've been taking
the
um gosh, at least I've been taking I26
for about two years. Dr. Wallik, you've
been eating AIDS a lot longer.
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. I've been eating eating
AIDS before I was born.
>> So, Dr. Well, like when we're talking
about the brain and the spinal cord,
that sheath that protects all of them,
that myelin sheath is made up of
cholesterol.
>> Is correct.
So, if you have a weakening in that
sheath
and it or it's diminished or very thin
or non-existent because of
cholesterol-lowering drugs, you're kind
of opening yourself up to a lot of pain,
discomfort, poor health conditions.
>> Well, poor health conditions which will
shorten your life considerably. Okay,
your life, not only are you miserable,
but you're sh your life is shortened.
Okay, instead of living to be 100, 110,
120 as you should, you'll die at 50 or
40 or something like that. Okay, because
everything in the brain and spinal cord
stops stops. Your heart stops, your your
stomach stops, um your lungs stop, your
kidneys, everything stops. Okay? And so
it's one of those things where um you
need to be, you know, the holidays are
coming up.
My favorite new books, okay? It's all in
your head. Okay? It's all in your head.
Okay? It covers about 50 different
diseases that occur when you have
osteoporosis of the skull, squeezing the
12 pairs of cranial nerves, and also
squeezing the what? Oh, the spinal cord.
So for the spinal cord we have a CD.
Okay.
The CD is entitled Where are we here?
Here we go. The CD is entitled it's all
in your head to prevent um and fixosis
of the skull and spinal cord. Okay.
It's one of those things where
There you go. You got it. And then of
course metabolic syndrome.
Um, this one you're you're kind of a
co-author there.
There you go. Okay. Metabolic syndrome.
Yeah. Metabolic syndrome. And this goes
back. It's even in the Old Testament.
Now, they don't name it in the Old
Testament, metabolic syndrome, but it
discusses the diseases, okay, of
obesity, abdominal obesity, um,
diabetes, and high blood pressure. And
so, this goes back, this disease goes
back to 200,000 years ago.
Now come um let's see here um when it
came to
a specific date uh what is it um
September 4th is it or 3rd or 4th?
>> September 4th of 1882. Is that the date
you're looking for?
>> Yeah. Okay. 1882. September 4th. Okay.
And um Thomas Edison pulled the switch,
turned on electricity, and our source of
minerals went away. Well, how could
electricity do that? Our source of
minerals went away. Well, for 200
million years, 200 million years. Now,
we found tools 3.3 million years old
just a couple days ago were in the
newspaper. Okay. Man-made tools 3.3
million years ago. Well, during those
times, people are using wood and coal as
fuel, putting the wood ashes in their
food for spice, putting wood ashes in
their gardens for fertilizer. Whatever
minerals were in the soil there came up
in in those plants and they're drinking
water.
>> Can you move your book? I just got a
note saying that it's muffling your
voice a little bit. Go ahead and put it
down. If you need it held up, just tell
me. I got your back.
>> Okay. Okay. [laughter]
Okay. At any rate, it's one of those
things where we can prevent and reverse.
I'm going to repeat that we can prevent
and reverse Alzheimer's disease,
Parkinson disease, multiple scerosis,
amalotropic gliocerosis, Huntington,
frontal temporal dementia, sharcom
tooth, bells pulsey, and many of the
others. Okay? And and doctors freak out
when I say that because that's how they
make their money is treating people with
these chronic genetic diseases. Well,
they're not genetic diseases. They're
not genetic diseases. They're
nutritional deficient diseases, okay?
They're cholesterol deficiency,
okay?
diseases. They're cholesterol deficiency
diseases. Okay? And so I
I just freak out when when when doctors
I go to meetings and the doctors saying,
"Okay, you got to stay away from all
this cholesterol and butter and all this
kind of stuff and eat margarine. Don't
don't drink milk anymore. Just that's
for babies." Well, I had to sue the FDA
eight times in federal court. I sued him
in federal court eight times. You've
heard me say this many times before.
to put nutrients into the baby formulas.
Okay? Because they were blaming the
mothers for the babies having SID
sentiment syndrome and they saying the
mothers were laying on them and
suffocating. They were telling people
that muscular which we had in animals we
could prevent and get rid of with just
some a few minerals in their alpha alpha
pellets. Okay. And we could get rid of
it in animals but the doctors saying it
was a genetic thing. And then then we
had cystic fibrosis. One of the most
Okay. And I I figured that one out and
got that figured, you know, the cause
prevention and reversal of cystic
fibrosis. I got fired from Yorks Primate
Center because of that because one of
their top people was creating the
cyrosis in the in the primates in the
Yorks Primate Center by giving them bad
diet and it was one of their top people.
So I didn't pick on the I didn't pick on
the person. I just said that, you know,
here's a diet for monkeys. This is the
only one for monkeys in in monkey um
facilities, primate facilities. And they
fired me.
>> That's because you tell it like it is,
doc.
>> You're not about, you know, making
somebody happy and and brownnosing.
You tell it like it is. Well,
>> we're looking for truth and and this is
why we do so well when it comes to these
diseases. Now, just to give you an idea,
and I go over this like once a month
probably, um doctors make in America
alone just treating the symptoms of
arthritis 626.8 billion just treating
the symptoms, not preventing or curing
it. Type two diabetes, they make $342
billion a year treating the symptoms of
diabetes, not preventing or curing it.
Heart disease, 316.8 8 billion obesity
$260 billion. Okay. My my favorite one
is osteoporosis.
The collection of of people from the
United States, Canada, and the EU,
European Union. Each year, the three of
these communities spend jointly 6.7,
not billion, but trillion, $6.7 trillion
dollar just to treat the symptoms of
osteoporosis. We can get rid of it in
weeks. Okay? And so this is something
this is a great holiday gift. Okay. And
this is why we came up with this dead
dogs lie. Okay. It's a DVD.
Okay. It's it's really really a complete
which I say thing on diseases that are
said to be genetic and so on. It's
really everybody should have at least
one of these in their family. And then
once a month show it. Show it once a
month. you'll see something new every
time you see it. Okay? It's two hours
and eight minutes long. Okay? And it has
30 chapters listed on the back. And so
that's Dr. Lai. Dr. Milan likes someone
should go to jail. So it's the subtitle.
Someone should go to jail. She likes
that Dr. Milan. So that's how she she in
the Chinese community.
>> Well, Dr. Wallik, we have lots of
questions coming in. So I want to make
sure that we leave some room for
questions. You mentioned Christmas
holiday gifts. Folks, what better thing
to do than give somebody a gift of
better health or something that can help
them find better health?
That is what Dr. Wall created many years
ago. He has removed himself from
ownership of Youngevity so that he can
freely do the lectures that he's doing
with us and around the world without
people saying, "Well, you only do it
because you own the company and you're
making lots of money." Now, Dr. Wallik
makes his money from the sale of his
books. So, we want to make sure that
everybody has access to getting Dr.
Wallik's books. You can give them a call
at 8007554656.
Did I get it memorized yet?
>> Perfect. 8007554656
and get your copies of Dr. Wallik's
books. You can find a whole list of the
books that they offer on the website
drjwallik.com.
And as far as gifts go, Dr. Wallik, over
here on my shoulder, I have the advent
calendar. brand new um from Youngevity
filled of goodness and goodies, things
that aren't even available through their
website. So, if you're into opening up
an advent calendar, folks, we've got one
that is just absolutely amazing
um that I'm excited to start opening up
those drawers and finding out what's
inside. Well, Dr. Well, like I said, we
have many uh questions coming in. The
first one is can cholesterol be too low?
>> Oh yeah.
When it's too low, when cholesterol is
too low, again you wind up with
deminating disease of the brain and
spinal cord, Alzheimer's disease,
Parkinson's disease, multiple cerosis,
amotrophic
sclerosis, ALS, um Huntington's Korea,
Sharcom tooth, Bell's P all those things
and all the other milein deficient
diseases are caused by either low or no
cholesterol. Okay. Also, you're not
you're not gonna be interested in sex.
You're gonna spend all your time working
on your car, but you're not gonna be
interested in sex because 85%
>> Are you telling?
>> What?
>> I work all the time. What are you trying
to say, Doc?
>> Okay. It's one of those things where sex
hormones
require cholesterol. They're 85% by
volume cholesterol. So, you cut out
cholesterol out of your diet, there
ain't nobody home anymore. Okay. For
either the men or the women. Okay. So
your sex life just goes into the tank
because I'm just so you know you're
you're at your job and people are saying
how's your sex life going Frank? What's
sex life? I even think about that
anymore.
>> We don't talk about that on the job Dr.
Wallik. But uh we definitely want to
make sure that we choose the right
partners as well. So not just with
anyone everywhere whatever. But next
question Dr. Wallick as you mentioned
ALS in that list of conditions that you
just read off. The question is is ALS
more complicated and time consuming to
address rather over Parkinson's.
Um I think it's one of those things that
um um Parkinson disease
um is is
what should I say it's a very very
narrow symptom tree.
Okay. Whereas something like um multi
Parkinson disease
>> ALS
>> so like ALS it is it's kind of like a an
analogy is you're looking at an
electrical panel on the house and with
ALS the insulation is missing so things
are shortening out. Is that like the
insulation? Would that be compared to
like the myelin sheath that's protecting
the brain and the nerves?
>> Well, the myelin sheath is
protecting the brain and the spinal cord
and the nerves particularly, you know,
the tense cranial nerve, the big vagus
nerve. I I get calls
sometimes five times a week. People call
me and say, "My my doctor wants to
amputate my toes." Why? Well, they're
burning all the time. Would you have any
ring in your ears? Yeah. Well, that's
because you have osteoporosis skull
squeezing the tan or the Vegas nerve.
The Vegas nerve goes through your brain
all the way down into your toes. And
that burning in your toes is due to
what's going on in your brain. And did
your doctor say anything about the ring
in your ears? He said, "No, you just got
to get used to that. You know, you're 50
years old. You got to get used to it."
No. No. And so we put him on a program
and in two weeks time the burning in the
feet go away because we made the the
vagus nerve happy by giving him some raw
materials to make myelin.
>> So ALS can be those that are
experiencing symptoms of ALS can benefit
from nutrition as well.
>> Absolutely. Can reverse they can reduce
and eliminate these diseases.
Alzheimer's disease, Parkinson disease,
multiple scerosis, amalotropic
glandrosis, Huntington's Korea, front of
temporal dementia, charcoal marie tooth,
Bell's pulsey, cervical spondylosis,
carpal tunnel synrome and all the rest
of the 50y. Okay, [clears throat]
we can prevent them. Okay, and we can
also reverse them once you have them.
The body was made by the good Lord and
God made our body to take raw materials
from the garden of Eden and maintain a
repair cell. Well, when people moved out
of the Garden of Eden, they moved away
from the land flowing with milk and
honey, suddenly now every place didn't
have all the nutrients they needed.
Okay? But the people who stayed in the
Garden of Eden and the land flowing with
milk and honey, they're the ones who
live to be 100 120. right now the
Pakistanis, the Hanzas and the Himalayan
mountains, they're the longest lived
people in the world. 122 years is their
average. That's their average 122 years.
And the interesting the most interesting
piece that we got when we studied them
here recently,
the most interesting piece was is that a
single medical doctor
in the Hanza
tribal communities. So they are all
focused about it's well it's the
nutrition it's what they're putting in
their in their bodies but most
importantly it's those minerals that are
flowing down that are watering their
crops that even the pasture land that
their animals are grazing off of is more
nutrientdense than what we have here in
the United States and in most places
around the world.
>> That's true. That is true. So, doc nan
Nancy puts up a comment here. Um, and I
absolutely agree with it. She says,
"It's easy to prove to skeptics Dr.
Wallik did this has done for several
decades before longevity was even
founded. You've been writing books since
the 1960s, Dr. Wallik."
>> Yes. before the majority of people that
are saying the exact same thing that
you're saying right here started saying
it within the last 10 years. You have
been teaching this, preaching this, and
wanting to get this out to the world.
So, I want to um go to the first hand
that is up because we do have some hands
and only a few minutes left. And AJ,
what questions are you bringing in
today? Please unmute yourself.
>> Hey, Dr. Wallik.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Uh, couple questions. One is from
Orurin, who emails in. I don't have any
hydro weight, but he says he just
ordered
uh the 90 mineral liquid and fatty acid.
Uh, he is dealing with uh schizophrenia
and a mood disorder.
Uh, what what else should he be taking
is what he's
>> 26. I26
needs to take either the chewables, the
capsules or the powder. Okay. Three
doses a day and he'll rebuild the
milein, the white matter the brain is
found and all that'll go away.
>> Fantastic. And then I have a couple that
I've been working with for a little
while. Uh the husband Neil has has
Parkinson's
and he can't move. He he can't move
without this. He he did say though his
tremors have improved uh since he's been
on the products. So he he he can write
now whereas before he was unable to
write well at all. Uh so that's improved
a lot for him. Uh his wife is dealing
with some scoliosis.
Uh but as far as Neil goes,
uh w without that medication that
produces the dopamine, he can't move.
Like when when that dopamine medication
runs out, he's having difficulty moving.
Is there a suggestion that we can
>> Yeah, he needs to ramp up on his I26. He
should be taking three three times a day
then. Okay. Three doses either the
tubles, the capsules, or the powder.
Okay. three doses three times a day. He
also needs the ultimate daily classic
tablets for circulation into the brain
and spinal cord. Okay? Take three of
those twice a day. And then of course he
needs the 90 essential nutrients. All 90
essential nutrients. You just can't pick
and choose things. [clears throat] You
got to take it all.
>> Absolutely.
>> Yeah. And wouldn't hurt. Remember stick
of butter a day keeps a doctor away. Use
butter and cooking. No margarine. And
then of course um [clears throat]
dairy. Um so he can get sugar-free ice
cream and that kind of stuff is made out
of milk and and cream.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay.
>> So So you think you should stay away
from sugar?
>> Uh yeah.
Okay. Okay.
You you know what you are, right, Doc?
>> What?
>> You're the man.
>> Oh, thank you. [laughter]
All right, thank you. Great questions,
AJ. Let's go to Mary. Mary, go ahead and
unmute yourself. What question do you
have for Dr. Wallik today?
>> Yes. Hello, Dr. Wallik.
>> Hi. How can we help you?
>> Yes. Uh, I have a client that's very
interested in starting the Mighty
Mighty90 program. He's 84 years old, uh,
225 pounds, about six feet. He has uh
diabetes, high blood pressure,
degenerative discs in the back with pain
down the hip and leg where the leg gets
numb periodically
and he has kidney disease and his
concern is outside of that uh the doctor
tells him that he should not take
magnesium because of the kidney disease.
So, uh although he wants to do the
program, he's very hesitant on the
magnesium aspect. What what can I uh
help him and how can you help me with
that?
>> Well, you say he weighs 223,
>> correct?
>> Okay. So, you need to game off all the
bad foods. No fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils, no gluten, no wheat
brinos, no buckwheat, no sugar, no
carbon drinks. the diet ones need to go
because they [clears throat] neutralize
excuse me stomach acids so you cannot um
digest food or or absorb minerals. Then
[clears throat] needs two healthy brain
and heart packs a month a full dose of
thing twice a day. Needs two bottles a
month of the ultimate daily classic
tablets for circulation into the brain
and the spinal cord and the liver and
the kidneys and so forth. Um the kidneys
will be happier with the ultimate daily
classic tablets. take three twice a day
or it could even take three three times
a day to start with and after a couple
weeks or a month or so drop it down to
three twice a day for maintenance. And
then uh let's see here the I26 I26 for
rebuilding the white matter in the brain
and spinal cord. Uh that helps all those
kind of things everything from memory to
balance and so forth. Trimmers.
Um, also because of all the bony things
going on, it wouldn't hurt also to get
the calati, take an ounce of that twice
a day. I do that and I only weigh only
weigh like I don't know sometimes 130,
sometimes 140 pounds, but I take um two
doses a day of the calati. Okay? And I
mix that with the plant derived
colloidal minerals, an ounce of each
twice a day. All right? And so this is
going to cover, I think, everything we
need to deal with there. Did I miss
anything?
>> Uh, just what should he tell his doctor
about the magnesium issue he's concerned
about?
>> Well, I don't know that the doctor knows
what he's talking about.
>> Okay.
>> Because if he says stay away from
magnesium, just about every multiple,
every multiple on the market will have
magnesium. The only thing that doesn't
have magnesium in is vitamin C, vitamin
A, that kind of thing. One by one by one
by one. And you're not going to take all
90 essential nutrients with. Okay.
With one by one by one by one,
>> right? Okay. So, there's no concern with
kidney disease.
>> No, but you got to take the ultimate
daily classic to make the kidney.
>> Okay. Perfect. Thank you, doc. I
appreciate it.
>> Hey, you bet. Keep up the great work. We
appreciate all you do.
>> Thank you.
Thank you, Mary and Dr. Wick. There's so
many different functions of the body
that require magnesium. So, shutting off
your magnesium supply, it's just going
to add more discomfort, right?
>> Very. Yeah. Problematic. Absolutely.
>> Well, let's next go to Key. Keely, go
ahead and unmute yourself. You're on
live with Dr. Wallik.
>> Uh, good afternoon everybody. Um, doc, I
have um actually it came out of a a
tragedy. Uh, there was a child that died
here in Ohio um this last week and she
died with her mother um in the house.
She was 12 years old and she had
something called Angelmen's
um Angelman syndrome and they said that
these children are called smiling
puppets that they said that it was a
rare disorder caused by a loss of
function of a single gene. It affects
about 500,000
um people a year. Motor skill and
cognitive delays. Um difficulty suckling
and eating, gastrointestinal. Um usually
end up with curvature of the spine,
sclerosis. Um and then they never walk.
Sometimes they're non-verbal. The issue
came from an educator who we were
talking about the situation and she
said, "I wish there was something I
could do." and she happens to be um a
client of mine with longevity and she
said, "I hate to tell you this, but I've
got four more kids that are like this."
I said, "Where are you going?" And she
says, "I'm going," she goes from school
district to school district within a 100
miles of each other. And what's in a 100
miles of that location is a burillium
plant and a nuclear power plant. So what
they were asking is, is there anything
that we can do for these four other
children that are 4, 8, 10, and 12?
>> Yes. They need to get rid of all the bad
foods. Get on the kids totty. Okay. Get
on the kids totty. Just read the label
for dosages. Kids totty. They think it's
they think it's fruit juice, so they'll
like it. They also need the I26. They'll
like the chewables. They can each the
little ones take one chewable. The
bigger ones take two chewables. They'll
rebuild the brain and the spinal cord.
They need again the kids tatty to get
them multiple. And it wouldn't hurt for
them, you know, for energy during the
day. Don't let them have colas and sweet
drinks and things like that. Get them on
the rebound. Has 150 nutrients in here.
Okay. This is built for Raleigh, great
basketball player. his career was over
because he had um arthritis in his hip
and his knees and he had all kinds of
tremors. He probably had Parkinson's
disease. So, we got him um on the
healthy bone and joint pack, which was a
healthy start pack. And then I came up
with the glucco gel and added the glucel
pack. We call it the healthy bone and
joint pack. Got him on that. And um
because they had fired him, he's out of
work as a b professional basketball
player for three months. um after years
of being very successful basketball
player and um came up with a rebound for
him and he played for nine more years
after I rebuilt him. He got he got his
job back. He made $134 million. $134
million. $134 million.
Okay.
Um
after we fixed him with all these
nutrients.
>> So Dr. there's a possibility of having
some toxicity. What can they do to to
find out if there's toxicity and what
can they do as a response to toxicity
whether it's in these kiddos, their
parents, the whole community.
>> Okay. [clears throat]
If people are concerned about toxicity,
they can get a hair analysis. The book
rare earth cures uh goes into how to
collect the hair, where to ship it, and
uh it helps you interpret it. But also
when you get the hair analysis back, uh
you can uh you know call us on the
program here and we'll walk you through
it or you can actually um send a hair
sample to us and we'll run it to a lab
near us and and kind of read it before
it gets sent to you. So you'll have the
answer before it gets sent to you
because we'll read it for you. Okay? So
you can call the 1800 7554656.800
1 800755-4656
and ask them how to collect and ship the
the um uh hair sample to you to us so we
can actually run the information for
you. Those are your options.
>> All right, thank you so much for that.
And Key, great question. as you know
it's a shame that things are happening
>> um to our kiddos that one I mean it
could be toxicity from mama whenever she
was be pregnancy even right um but
making sure that our families are
healthy is our top priority Dr. Wallik
let's go to Gloria Gloria go ahead and
unmute yourself
>> hello Dr. wallet.
>> Hi, Gloria. How can we help you?
>> Hey, hey, I have someone who's 64 years
old, weighs about 180 and
58, is complaining about ringing in the
ears.
>> Okay. Well, that's an easy one. They've
got approach to the skull, squeezing the
seventh and the eighth cranial nerves.
They need to get a hold of the book.
It's all in your head. Okay. It's all in
your head. Wouldn't hurt to get the
book. It's all in your head. And also
the CD that goes along with it. All
right. And it's one of those things
where
where um
page six is my favorite my favorite
page. Of course,
>> I got it for you, Doc.
>> Okay, you got it. Okay,
page six. Okay, you see the top picture
is an Armal skull. It's a quarter of an
inch thick. The top of the skull has
been removed at autopsy and the the
camera is looking down on the brain, but
you see the skull is a quarter inch
thick. The bottom one, they took the top
of the skull off looking down on the
brain, but the the skull is an inch and
a half to two inches thick. That's
because it had osteopos skull. That's
not bone, that's scar tissue taking the
place of the lost bone. Okay? And in the
next page, page seven, turn flipped page
shows a picture of the brain and all
where all the 12 pairs of cranial nerves
go, all the organs and so forth. And
then there's a chapter for each of the
cranial nerves. Okay, the next ch the
next chapter there you see next to a
page you see all those gray lines and
white lines and so forth. Each one of
those is a chapter that covers what
diseases are caused by one of the
cranial nerves being squeezed. There's
over 50 different diseases being caused
by the brain squeezing these cranial
nerves because of osteoposis of the
skull. And doctors love osteoprosis
skull. They don't get taught this in
medical school. I'll repeat that. They
do not get taught this in medical
school. I had to find this out. I'm
doing autopsies and I'm finding osteopro
skull in the human bodies. Then I go to
I look at the clinical records that were
collected over a period of one, two,
three, four, five, eight, 10 years.
There's no mention
in any of them. And so that's why I
figure, oh, we better come out with a
little book on this one is that I can
add
30 to 50 years to your life.
Okay.
>> Uh, and what's recommended for it?
>> Well, they need the health hard pack.
Get rid of all the bad foods.
>> One sec.
>> Oops. Got to get rid of that. Sorry
about that. Got to get rid of all the
bad foods.
>> [clears throat]
>> um take the heler and heart pack a full
dose of everything twice a day. Um so
it'll be two helband and heart packs per
month. Then they need the um also uh I
go ahead and give them the I26
okay to rebuild all the myelin the white
matter of the brain and spinal cord and
then the ultimate daily classic tablets.
three of those fights today get
circulation up into the heart into the
kidneys and the brain
and you'll see miracles.
>> And don't forget
>> Yeah, don't forget the glucco gel,
one per 10 pounds. So, you'd split that
out throughout the day. And also the MSM
Ultra.
Those things help to uh support
connective tissue, putting it where it's
supposed to be. and um also all of the
the function of the body, the bones to
keep them strong and healthy as well.
>> I use MSM Ultra just for prevention.
>> Yep. And take that two, three times a
day. In severe cases, three three times
a day when you're over 150 pounds. So,
Dr. Well, like did you know that Theo's
career earnings with the MDA MBA
>> 1004?
No, no, no. 102,351,958.
>> Wow.
>> So, I think he did pretty well, Doc.
after rebuilding them, he was able to
bounce back and the majority of his
career was after
after being rebuilt. So that is
absolutely fantastic. Let's go to Coach
Rod with the final question. Coach Rod,
welcome to Daily with Doc. What
questions do you have today? Good
afternoon, Doc. How you doing?
He said,
>> "Good. How are you doing?
What's your question?
>> My question is I have a male 575
pounds has vinyl lago
>> disease. Yes sir.
>> So he's got what's his symptoms?
>> The discoloration of the skin kind of
like what Michael Jackson had I think or
>> Okay. So a loss of skin color is is he
dark skinned person?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So he's losing some color in his
skin.
>> The black black meal.
>> Okay. Yeah. Get rid of all the bad
foods. No fried foods, no processed
meat, no oils, no gluten, no wheat
around oats, no buckwheat, no sugar, no
carbonated drinks. Even the diamond's
got to go. Needs one healthy brain and
heart pack per 100 pounds of body
weight. If he weighs 150 pounds or more,
he needs two healthy brain heart packs
of full dose of breakfast, full dose of
dinner time. [clears throat]
needs, excuse me, also needs the plant
derived colloidal minerals. Okay, take
an an ounce of that twice a day. Also
needs the hair, skin, and nails. Go
ahead and take hair, skin, and nails.
Take three of those twice a day. It'll
be two bottles a month because they're
tiny little bottles. Okay, two bottles a
month of hair, skin, and nails. And
then, um, let's see. What am I missing
here, Rebecca?
Uh, did you did you double up on the
selenium? The ultimate selenium, Dr.
Wallik.
>> Okay. Double up on the ultimate
selenium. Okay. Take three selenium at
breakfast, lunch, and dinner. Okay.
It'll definitely help there.
>> The the glucco gel the glucco gel will
help build skin also.
Okay.
>> Okay. Doc, one more quick question,
please. I have a guy uh taking the 90
for his blood pressure and he's taking
the ultimate daily classic, but he can't
take pills anymore. Do you have anything
in liquid form to help the blood
pressure?
>> Well, you take the 90 essential
nutrients. Take the Get rid of all the
bad foods. Take the 90 essential
nutrients. Take the ultimate daily
classic tablets. Do we have daily
classic and liquid?
No, we don't have Ultimate Daily Classic
and liquid, but we do have the cardio
sticks, Dr. Wild, that help support
heart health.
>> Okay, the cardio sticks. Try that. Okay,
but they need the 90 essential nutrients
as the base. Get rid of all the bad
foods so they can absorb the nutrition.
That should uh that should be easily
going away.
And in the liquid nutrition, you can
easily find the pig pack. May not need
the pig pack plus, but it's called the
pig pack or even the mighty 90. And
those EFAs, you can puncture those. You
can chew those. Um, you got to get them
in your body no matter what it takes,
>> right, Doc?
>> Okay. Thank you so much.
>> Okay. Yeah, you just give us some
feedback in a couple weeks. Let us know
how it's going.
We are doing.
>> All right. Thank you so much. And Rod is
one of our co-hosts. So, you can stay up
on the line as I'd like to have all of
our co-hosts up on the screen with us.
Dr. Wallik, we could not do this program
without the support of our co-hosts as
each and every one of them have a vital
position um in helping to make this
program a success. So doc, these are
just a few of the thousands of
individuals who believe in your message
and want to make sure the message gets
out. Um I know around the world there
are less than a 100,000
uh independent distributors folks. So it
is not a saturated market. There are so
many people that are not getting reached
when it comes to the importance of
nutrition. So, if you have even a little
bit of interest in wanting to help
others, make sure that you get back with
the person that shared this program with
you. If there is no one to thank, give
us a call at 855-9493377.
Again, 855-9493377
and let our team member know how you
want to be part of the solution. That is
also the phone number if you yourself
want to find a better health journey. So
again 855-9493377.
That is for people who are not already
working with somebody who are not
already taking the longevity products.
Folks, there's so many different
nutritional
products and options out there. The
reason why I support this one is because
I tried so many of those others. I tried
a little bit of this, a little bit of
that, even a lot of a lot a lot of
different things and I never got the
results I was looking for. I got on the
Youngevity program. It was a system. It
was simple to follow and I got results.
Plain and simple. You give your body
exactly what it needs, which Dr. Wallik
through his many autopsies and pathology
research expeditions
found out what exactly that is. He put
it into formulas so that we can benefit
from them.
We invite you to give Dr. Wallik and his
options 90 days.
90 days, folks. And within those 90
days, you will feel results. That does
not mean that they treat, prevent, cure
any disease. But folks, when you give
your body what it needs, the body itself
can do some amazing things. And
depending on how you are in this journey
of health and how far down that poor
health journey you're you've gone will
determine what is possible and how much
progress you get. But it does take a few
choices in your lifestyle that need to
be changed and then adding a nutritional
program like what Young has. So Dr.
Wallik, we have on with us Coach Rod
who's out there bringing in questions
from the field and letting people in.
Thank you so much, Coach Rod, for all
that you do. We also have Roselyn
Sanchez who is our executive production
manager um making sure that the stream
is going smoothly and making sure that
we stay organized on task. We have
Albert who is joining us from South
Africa and he's making sure that
everybody gets into the Zoom quickly and
keeping an eye on things for us. Thank
you so much Albert. We have Marilyn who
is busy probably the busiest one of us
all. Okay, I I I got to just be honest
here as she is doing dictation and
putting what is being said into type
into the chat. So, if you're not joining
us here live and you'd like to see what
is actually being said because you can't
take notes fast enough, she types faster
than Doc can speak and that's pretty
fast. So, super super thankful for
Marilyn and all that she does.
We also have um Sherry and her little
one that's there with her joining us as
she's part of the tech team and um
helping to get everything set up so that
we can stream to the different
platforms. And we have AJ who is
responsible for all the different
platforms that we are on which include
Apple TV app, Vimeo, Roku TV app,
Rumble, Facebook. You can find us on
YouTube at Critical Health News Channel.
Find us on Twitter, on the Daily with
Doc feed, iHeart Radio, Spotify, Apple
Podcasts, Castbox, Amazon Music and
Amazon Podcasts, Overcast Fm app under
Daily with Doc, Pod Pocketcasts,
Brideon, and Tik Tok under Daily with
Doc. So, make sure that you find us
whatever your favorite uh platform app
is. we're probably there. And if we're
not there, send us an email and let us
know where you are or would prefer to to
watch us or listen to us by sending an
email to info@dailywithdoc.com.
Again, that's info@dailywithdoc.com.
That's the same email that if you want
to reach out to us through email to be
part of the solution, use that email as
well. If you have questions and one we
didn't get to your question today or
you're just watching us at a different
time and you would like to send us
questions, questions at
dailywithdoc.com.
Again, questions at dailywithdoc.com.
Folks,
we did this because one, we know the
value of nutrition. to we see a hurting
world and it breaks our heart especially
after we have found what it is that can
change all that. The Institute of
Holistic Health has putting put together
a coaching program for a certified
holistic health coach that teaches about
the four areas of health, how they're
affected by nutritional deficiencies,
the solutions to those deficiencies. But
they don't just stop at that. They look
at all seven aspects, all eight rather,
seven additional from health when it
comes to living a life
abundant, not just physically, but
emotionally, mentally, spiritually,
financially.
We invite you to check us out by going
to coachwithdoc.com.
That's coach witheg.com.
Get more information about our holistic
health coach course. And if you'd like
to save 50%, make sure that you give us
a call at 855-9493377.
Again, coachwithdoc.com
for more information about our coaching
program that offers
50% off if you give us a call at 855
9493377
or get back with the person that shared
this program with you. They may have
their very own link. So, make sure that
you ask them about the coaching program
and how you can be part of it as a
certified holistic health. Whether it's
for your own health, your community's
health
or together, we're helping save the
world, folks. That's what Dr. Wall put
this crusade all together for. Until
next time. Oh, we have we have
pharmacist bin Bites.
Is that tonight?
Yes, tonight. You can check out
pharmacist bin Bites. You can watch the
live stream on any of the options or
most of the options that I read off just
above especially Rumble, YouTube,
Facebook. Make sure that you catch us.
Make sure that you get on there. Let us
know that you are there. Send us some
likes. Send us some loves. And if you
have questions for pharmacist Ben, send
them to
ajailywithdoc.com.
No info at dailywithdocck.com.
All right, info@dailywithdoc.com
if you have questions for pharmacist Ben
Fuches that uh we can use on pharmacist
bin bites and with coach AJ um that pop
up here and there and everywhere.
If you are in Newark, New Jersey area or
within uh subway distance, driving
distance, however you want to get there,
there is an event coming up March 4th,
3rd, 2nd. Sorry, March 2nd. So, I call
you in on the
>> No, AJ, take it away.
>> November.
>> I would think it's November. November
2nd. Saturday, November 2nd. And we'll
have more details coming up where we're
gonna have the fabulous Becca Dukes and
Ruth Ellen Sanchez with us live and in
person in Newark, New Jersey. So you
might want to show up at the Robert
Treat Hotel on the second and we'll get
more information.
>> Yes. And we also you need to RSVP folks.
So RSVP so that we know what size room
to be setting up. And we also are going
to be having an appearance. We don't
know for certain. He's trying to make it
happen in physical appearance with
pharmacist Benf Fuches there as well.
You can RSVP by emailing info
nutrientshelp.com.
So until next time, thanks AJ. Bye for
now.
Welcome to [music] Daily with Doc and
Becca. This program is for educational
purposes only. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, [music]
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician.
Testimonials [music] are shared as
individual experiences of the individual
sharing their testimony. Results vary
and [music] may not be typical. We do
not make any claims regarding health or
income. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We are
honored to have the founding [music]
father of the science of epigenetics
guiding us with the best options to
obtain or maintain optimal health, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
Number
two.
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. The
content is not intended to diagnose,
treat, cure, or prevent any diseases,
[music] nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Testimonials are shared as individual
[music]
experiences of the individual sharing
their testimony. Results vary and
[music] may not be typical. We do not
make any claims regarding health or
income. As an empowered individual, you
[music] do have options available. We
are honored to have the founding [music]
father of the science of epigenetics
guiding us with the best options to
obtain or maintain optimal health. Dr.
Joel Wallik.
Welcome to daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational [music]
purposes only. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take
[music] the place of your primary care
physician. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the individual
sharing their testimony. Results [music]
vary and may not be typical. We do not
make any claims regarding health or
income. As an empowered [music]
individual, you do have options
available. We are honored to have the
founding father of the science of
epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health, Dr. Joel Wallik.